"Most of the hypotheses that Kepler
developed to explain physical forces were
later rejected as inconsistent to Newtonian
theory, [or we have] No error." So, the
part that seemed a little strange to me
is when they talk about, "inconsistent to".
You don't say that you are "inconsistent
to" something, you say that you are
"inconsistent [with]" something. Study A
is not "inconsistent to" Study B, you would
say, Study A is "inconsistent [with]"
Study B. So, this should be "inconsistent
[with]", and if I were to rewrite this,
I would write this as: "Most of the
hypotheses that Kepler developed to
explain physical forces were later rejected
as [being] inconsistent [with] Newtonian
theory". That sounds a lot better,
"inconsistent [with]". So, the error is in D.